the battle over parental rights
literally turning into one things
getting violent outside of school board
meeting in Glendale California antifa
thugs brawling with parents who were
protesting the school board's push to
incorporate lgbtq plus materials into
the curriculum
[Music]
parental groups are also coming under
attack the far left Southern Poverty Law
Center smears multiple parents rights
organizations as hate and
anti-government groups lumping the moms
of Liberty and with the likes of
neo-nazis and the KKK this splc stuff
they're just a bunch of moms where do
they come off labeling them like there's
a group called it's called parents
defending education that's what they
call themselves like the parental rights
group and they have been basically they
try to do things like highlight Public
Schools misusing covid funds for example
especially to hire Consultants teaching
CRT they have basically been attacked
not only by the splc but remember also
possibly by the Attorney General oh
right right I could say this is the same
group so I think what's happening is you
are seeing a possible
Tipping Point in this matter when you
have when antifa has to come out and
fight parents something is happening and
that means that parents are out there
they wanting to be more engaged because
they're realizing that the left is
trying to take over their parenting as
well as the education of their children
they don't like it they want to be more
involved and that's going to be a big
part of the election if you think about
Governor Glenn Younkin of Virginia when
he won basically on that issue and I
don't know how it will turn out in 2024
but you're going to hear a lot about it
on the campaign Trail but Judge Jeanine
antifa is just an idea oh it's a myth
it's a myth it's not even an idea you
know what I love why is it always that
the ones on the left are wearing the
masks right if they are not the fascist
show your face don't be worried about it
if you're in the right why do you need
to cover your identity right okay but
look it seems that the schools right now
are ground zero for the cultural war
that is breaking out right now and you
know the fact that parents want to be
involved in their kids education because
covid lifted the veil of what they're
teaching our kids which explains why so
many corporate heads are woke and and
clearly you know off the rails uh it
simply means that it is really time now
to get involved education is a local
issue and parents now know their
strength as Dana said from what happened
to Virginia Loudoun County uh and the
left wants to Simply destroy education
as we know it and the idea of Joe Biden
who has been talking to the school
teachers and there are kids when they're
in school you know no they're not your
kids they were never your kids there are
kids and we'll decide what we want them
to learn and they they the left has
people convinced that we want our kids
to continue to be white supremacists and
oppressors and that's what education is
all about and they have to fight it no
they don't just teach the right the
rigors of Education have you ever ever
gotten into a brawl outside of your
child's School Harold Virginia I I have
not that's a dis that picture is
unsettling and it's on it's unfortunate
we we parents can agree or disagree
about how and what their kids should be
taught and because I may disagree with
someone I would say that the Southern
Poverty Law Center who's done great work
in other areas you should you should
denounce this this is no one's a
terrorist because you happen to disagree
with them I agree with you judge we
should return to many of the basics in
science and math and reading uh the core
of what hap what helps kids be able to
critically think I probably differ with
some around a table I should say differ
with some who've been we've been
presented and portrayed because I'm the
the greatest gift my high school in
college and law school education gave me
was the ability to think critically and
to be accepting of of ideas and Views
that I didn't know a whole lot about
like for instance you just presented
about New England Dark Day those who
believe that climate change is is
induced by all these terrible things
like the end engine and gas and this and
that to your point there was not a
combustible engine that democrats should
not not want that to be taught just as
some who may think that teaching about
race and and school and and banning AP
History and AP African-American history
is a good thing this is part of our this
is part of our history The Good the Bad
and even the unfortunate and the great
thing about our history is that we've
gotten stronger and better because we
stand on it so I don't the terrorism
language all this stuff has gotten crazy
people are afraid of ideas they're
afraid of thoughts and I hope parents
can get together and figure out how you
get back to the basics and the basics
involve learning a little something
about our country that may make us at
times a little unsettled I don't think
anybody's arguing about learning history
who's doing the labeling it's the splc
calling these people terrorists and I
agree with you they used to say this is
Banning books I mean not that true not
true
they're just books that are being moved
from one part of the library to another
so it's not involving like Banning the
book means getting taking a book out it
just means you can't have it in one area
but can I can I just focus on this and
destroy you in front of millions all
right the Espio the splc is the
equivalent of canceled cultures bad
housekeeping seal it's designed to ruin
lives right by labeling them as a hate
group rather than your rather than your
suggestion of debating the actual ideas
you can't do that because they're
labeled they were labeling you
undebatable because you are a terrorist
and they've lost a lawsuit because the I
think it was Majin Noah's over this but
I don't think you can just blame the S
this new splc alone like you can blame
Charles Manson but the real hate should
also be directed at his family who
committed the crimes and the equivalent
of his followers with the splc is the
media and these weak bloggers and and
reporters and hacks who would type up
splc's latest smear as objective news
portraying splc as like an expert in
Terror pretending it's a legit outfit
when it actually had morphed into the
very thing that it used to condemn I
mean that's I mean they are trying to
ruin people's lives I mean that's that
goes online these groups they have to
answer to it that's that's a deliberate
attempt to destroy someone's life can I
add something because Google for example
leans on the splc's maps and their
research and they help decide who's
going to get either blocked or banned on
social media well the five is now
labeled the svlc a hate groups are there
and also Harold's a hate group Harold
it's a one-man age group 350 plus books
have been banned in Florida school
districts since last year who's your son
what never
never heard of them that's a hate group
the Miami all right we gotta go I wanna
Brian Kilmeade I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now